Algunos de Uds. al escuchar esto se sentirán tristes.
Después de todo, EE.UU. está profundamente dedicado
a esta idea de superación económica,
en la que las generaciones deben ser "mejores" a la anterior,
ganar más, comprar más, ser más.
Hemos exportado este sueño por todo el mundo,
así niños en Brasil y China, e incluso Kenia,
heredan nuestra expectativa insaciable
de querer más.
Pero cuando leí esta encuesta histórica por primera vez,
en realidad no me entristeció.
Lo sentí como una provocación.
"Mejores"... ¿según qué estándar?
¿Es "mejor" encontrar un empleo seguro
donde permanecer el resto de la vida?
Esos empleos casi no existen.
La gente cambia de empleo, cada 4.7 años de promedio.
Y se estima que para el 2020,
cerca de la mitad de los estadounidenses trabajarán por cuenta propia.
Bien, ¿"mejor" es solo un número?
¿Se trata de ganar tanto como posible?
Por esa medición singular cometemos errores.
El ingreso medio per capita ha sido igual desde el 2000,
ajustado por la inflación.
Así, ¿"mejor" es conseguir una gran casa con una cerca blanca?
Pocos lo logran.
Casi cinco millones de personas perdieron sus hogares en la Gran Recesión,
y muchos enfrentamos seriamente hasta lo indecible
o nos engañaron, y en muchos casos nos depredaron,
para sostener esa proeza.
Las tasas de propiedad de vivienda están en el nivel más bajo desde 1995.
Es decir, no estamos encontrando un trabajo estable,
no estamos ganando tanto dinero,
y no estamos viviendo en grandes casas de lujo.
Que doblen las campanas mortuorias
para quienes hicieron grandes a EE.UU.
Pero,
¿son esas las mejores mediciones de la grandeza de un país,
de una vida bien vivida?
Creo que lo que engrandece a EE.UU. es su espíritu de reinvención.
Como consecuencia de la Gran Recesión,
más y más estadounidenses redefinen qué significa "mejor".
Resulta que tiene más que ver con la comunidad y la creatividad
que con dólares y centavos.
Pero seré clara:
el 14.8 % de los estadounidenses que viven en la pobreza necesita dinero,
simple y llanamente.
Y nosotros necesitamos políticas que nos protejan de la explotación
de los empleadores y las instituciones financieras.
Que nada de lo que sigue oculte que la brecha entre ricos y pobres
es algo profundamente inmoral.
Pero,
muy a menudo terminamos la conversación allí.
Hablamos de la pobreza como si fuese una experiencia monolítica;
y de los pobres como si fuesen exclusivamente víctimas.
Parte de lo que he aprendido en mi investigación
es que el arte de vivir bien
a menudo se practica con más maestría
entre los más vulnerables.
Ahora, si la necesidad es la madre de la invención,
he llegado a creer
que la recesión es la madre de la conciencia.
Eso nos confronta con preguntas profundas,
preguntas que nos daría pereza o evitaríamos
en momentos de relativa comodidad.
¿Cómo deberíamos trabajar?
¿Cómo deberíamos vivir?
Todos, nos demos cuenta o no,
buscamos respuestas a estas preguntas,
en el susurro de nuestros antepasados repicándonos los oídos.
Mi bisabuelo era un borracho de Detroit,
que a veces lograba mantener un trabajo en la fábrica.
Tuvo, por increíble que parezca,
21 hijos,
con una mujer, mi bisabuela,
que murió a los 47 años de cáncer de ovario.
Ahora, estoy embarazada de mi segundo hijo,
y ni siquiera puedo imaginar lo que debe haber pasado.
Y si están tratando de calcular... había seis pares de gemelos.
Así que mi abuelo, su hijo,
se convirtió en un vendedor ambulante,
y vivió el auge y la caída.
Mi papá creció atendiendo en la puerta a los cobradores de deudas,
fingiendo que sus padres no estaban en casa.
Llegó a quitarse los brackets con pinzas en el garaje,
cuando su padre admitió que no tenía dinero
para volver al dentista.
Así que mi padre, como era de esperar,
se convirtió en un abogado de bancarrota.
Podría escribir una novela, ¿verdad?
Estaba obsesionado por darnos una base segura
a mi hermano y a mí.
Me hice estas preguntas en unas generaciones de lucha.
Mis padres se aseguraron de que yo creciera en un terreno firme
que me permitiera cuestionarme, arriesgar y saltar.
E irónicamente, y probablemente a veces para su frustración,
es su firme compromiso con la seguridad
lo que me permite cuestionar su valor,
o al menos su valor como lo hemos definido históricamente
en el siglo XXI.
Así que profundicemos en esta primera pregunta:
¿Cómo deberíamos trabajar?
Deberíamos trabajar como nuestras madres.
Así es, hemos pasado décadas
tratando de encajar mujeres en un mundo de trabajo de hombres empresarios.
Muchas han hecho esfuerzos para encajar,
pero otras se han labrado un camino menos convencional,
creando un mosaico de sentido y dinero
con la suficiente flexibilidad para hacer lo que tienen que hacer
para quienes aman.
Mi mamá lo llamaba "simplemente hacer que funcione".
Hoy escucho que lo llaman "un portfolio de carrera".
Es igual cómo se llame,
cada vez más hombres ansían vidas plenas, no acosadas.
Albergan el deseo de ser padres e hijos presentes.
La artista Ann Hamilton dijo:
"El trabajo es una forma de conocer".
El trabajo es una forma de conocer.
En otras palabras, nuestro espacio de trabajo
es lo que entendemos por mundo.
Si esto es cierto, y creo que lo es,
las mujeres que se han preocupado desproporcionadamente por sus pequeños,
sus enfermos y sus ancianos,
se han beneficiado desproporcionadamente
del conocimiento más profundo existente:
conocer la condición humana.
Al dar prioridad al cuidado,
los hombres, en cierto sentido, demandan
la amplia gama de la existencia humana.
Esto significa que el horario 9 a 17 ya no funciona para todos.
Cumplir horarios se vuelve obsoleto, y también las escalas profesionales.
Industrias enteras nacen y mueren todos los días.
A partir de aquí, todo es no lineal.
Por eso debemos dejar de preguntarle a los niños:
"¿Qué quieres ser de mayor?"
Y empezar a preguntarles: "¿Cómo quieres ser de mayor?"
Su trabajo va a cambiar constantemente.
El denominador común son ellos.
Así que cuanto más conozcan sus dones
y creen equipos de colaboradores ideales,
"mejores" serán.
El desafío es reinventar la red de seguridad social
para adaptarse a esta creciente economía fragmentada.
Necesitamos beneficios portátiles para la salud.
Necesitamos políticas que reflejen que el mundo merece ser vulnerable
o cuidar de otros vulnerables,
sin llegar a la indigencia.
Tenemos que considerar seriamente una renta básica universal.
Tenemos que reinventar la organización del trabajo.
La promesa de un mundo del trabajo estructurado para encajar
nuestros valores del siglo XXI,
no una idea arcaica de traer a casa el sustento,
ya expiró hace tiempo...
pregúntenle a sus madres.
Ahora bien, ¿y la segunda pregunta?
¿Cómo debería vivir?
Deberíamos vivir
como los antepasados inmigrantes.
Cuando llegaron a EE.UU., a menudo
compartían apartamentos, tácticas de supervivencia, cuidado de niños,
siempre sabían cómo saciar un estómago más,
sin importar el alimento disponible.
Pero les dijeron que el éxito era dejar atrás el pueblo
y conseguir ese símbolo icónico del Sueño Americano,
la cerca blanca.
Y aún hoy, vemos una cerca blanca
y la asociamos a éxito, a posesión.
Pero dejando de lado el sentimentalismo,
eso en realidad nos divide.
Muchos estadounidenses rechazan la cerca blanca
y el tipo de vida altamente privatizado que eso conlleva,
y quieren recuperar la vida de pueblo,
y la interdependencia, en cambio.
50 millones, por ejemplo,
vivimos en hogares intergeneracionales.
Este número explotó con la Gran Recesión,
pero resulta que a la gente le gusta vivir así.
Dos tercios de los que viven con varias generaciones bajo un mismo techo
dicen que eso mejoró sus relaciones.
Algunas personas optan por compartir hogares no con familiares,
sino con otras personas que entienden los beneficios económicos y para la salud
de la comunidad diaria.
CoAbode, plataforma en línea para madres solteras que quieren compartir hogar
con otras madres solteras,
tiene 50 000 usuarias.
Y las personas mayores de 65 años son especialmente propensas
a buscar esas alternativas de vivienda.
Entienden que su calidad de vida
depende de una mezcla de soledad y solidaridad.
Algo cierto para todos nosotros si lo piensan,
jóvenes y ancianos por igual.
Durante mucho tiempo, hemos fingido que la felicidad es un rey en su castillo.
Pero toda la investigación demuestra lo contrario.
Demuestra que los más sanos, los más felices e incluso los más seguros,
en términos de cambio climático, delincuencia, todo eso,
son los estadounidenses que viven vidas entrelazadas con sus vecinos.
Ahora, he experimentado esto de primera mano.
En los últimos años he vivido en una comunidad de vivienda cooperativa.
Son 1,5 acres de árboles de caqui,
este arbusto de moras que serpentea por un jardín de la comunidad,
exactamente, por cierto, en medio del Oakland urbano.
Las nueve unidades están construidas para ser diferentes,
diferentes tamaños, diferentes formas,
y lo más verdes posibles.
Las grandes celdas solares negras y brillantes en los techos
suponen que nuestra factura de la luz rara vez excede
los USD 5 al mes.
Las 25 personas que vivimos allí tenemos diferentes edades, tendencias políticas
y profesiones,
y vivimos en casas que tienen todo lo que tendría un hogar típico.
Pero, además,
compartimos una cocina y comedor de tamaño industrial,
donde tenemos comidas en común dos veces por semana.
Cuando cuento que vivo así
a menudo veo dos reacciones extremas.
O dicen: "¿Por qué no todo el mundo practica esto?"
O dicen: "Suena horrible.
No me gustaría hacer eso".
Se los aseguro: hay un respeto sagrado por la privacidad entre nosotros,
pero también un compromiso con lo que llamamos "hospitalidad radical",
no la que anuncia Four Seasons,
sino la que dice que cada persona es digna de bondad,
punto final, final de la frase.
¿La mayor sorpresa para mí de vivir en una comunidad como esta?
Uno comparte el trabajo doméstico, la reparación, la cocina, la escarda,
pero también el trabajo emocional.
En lugar de depender únicamente de la unidad familiar idealizada
para satisfacer las necesidades emocionales,
hay dos docenas de otras personas a los que acudir
para hablar de un arduo día de trabajo
o analizar cómo lidiar con un profesor abusivo.
Los adolescentes de la comunidad suelen ir a un adulto que no es su padre
en busca de consejo.
Es lo que se llama "crianza revolucionaria",
este humilde reconocimiento
de que los niños son más saludables si tienen una gama más amplia de adultos
para emular o en quien confiar.
Resulta que los adultos son más saludables, también.
Es mucha presión,
tratar de ser esa familia perfecta detrás de la cerca blanca.
El "nuevo mejor", como lo denomino,
tiene que ver menos con la inversión en la familia perfecta
y más con invertir en el pueblo imperfecto,
ya sea con familiares que viven bajo un mismo techo,
una comunidad de covivienda como la mía,
o simplemente mucho vecinos que se comprometan a conocerse realmente
y cuidarse unos a otros.
Es de sentido común, ¿verdad?
Y, sin embargo, el dinero a menudo nos ha confundido
sobre lograr cosas.
La riqueza más fiable
se encuentra en la relación.
El "nuevo mejor" no es una perspectiva individual en absoluto.
De hecho, si Uds. son un fracaso o si creen ser un fracaso,
tengo buenas noticias:
podrían tener éxito en estándares que aún no conocen.
Quizá uno tiene ingresos mediocres pero es un padre magistral.
Quizá uno no puede permitirse el lujo de la casa de sus sueños,
pero hace fiestas de barrio legendarias.
Si uno tiene éxito con los libros,
las consecuencias de lo que estoy diciendo, podrían ser más sombrías.
Uno puede ser un fracaso en estándares que aprecia,
pero que el mundo no recompensa.
Solo uno puede saberlo.
Sé que no soy un homenaje
a mi bisabuela,
que vivió una vida tan corta y brutal,
al ganar suficiente dinero para pagar todas las comodidades.
No se puede escapar al sufrimiento ni encontrar sentido.
No hay algo lo suficientemente grande
como para borrar el dolor que ella debe haber soportado.
Soy un tributo a ella
si vivo una vida tan conectada y valiente como sea posible.
En medio de una incertidumbre generalizada,
es posible que, de hecho, estemos inseguros.
Pero podemos dejar que la inseguridad nos haga frágiles
o flexibles.
Podemos mirar hacia dentro, perder la fe en el cambio de las instituciones,
incluso perder la fe en nosotros mismos.
O podemos mirar hacia afuera,
tener fe en nuestra capacidad de llegar, conectar, crear.
Resulta que el mayor peligro
no consiste en no cumplir el Sueño Americano.
El mayor peligro es cumplir un sueño
en el que uno en realidad no cree.
No hagan eso.
Hagan lo más difícil, lo más interesante,
que es crear una vida en la que lo que hacen todos los días,
las personas a las que les dan su amor, ingenio y energía,
comparten lo más estrechamente posible lo que Uds. creen.
Eso, no es algo tan mundano como ganar dinero,
es un homenaje a sus antepasados.
Esa es una lucha hermosa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)